well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
daily mirrors political editor pippa
career
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace great to see both of
you
so to the front pages then uh one story
dominating really the great game robbery
is how
the sun describes the decision by six
english football teams
to split from other european
competitions and for a super league or
to create a super league without
qualification requirements but with a
large cash windfall
financial times picking up on that very
point suggesting participate
participating teams if i can say it
could be given a welcome
bonus of more than 250 million pounds
according to the metro the duke of
cambridge who is president of the fa
has expressed his objection to the
proposed move
royal reservations also the top line for
the daily telegraph
likewise the daily mail the headline
william cries
foul on league of greed the guardian
reporting the government is also unhappy
and has vowed to do
whatever it takes to stop the plan
perhaps echoing the sentiments of
liverpool fans
the eye declares you'll never go it
alone
for more papers to come in we will bring
you them as we see them pepper cream
mark wallace with their thoughts um
mark shall we kick off with the sun then
the great game
robbery um greed used elsewhere as well
there's been huge amounts of criticism
about this plan
there has indeed and i think the clubs
involved can't exactly be
surprised by that what i do find quite
amazing is that
in the year of our lord 2021
people including professional
footballers in various cases appear to
have only just noticed
that several of these really big clubs
are not actually clubs after all they're
just
giant machines interested in one thing
and that's money
this isn't something that's entirely new
of a new feature of these clubs what's
happening of course is that
they're now pursuing it in yet another
way that seeks to make
even more money off things that even
more people are unhappy about that isn't
a new trend it hasn't just started
and yet suddenly in some quarters people
are fanning themselves as if they've
only just noticed
yeah the sun their fans protested big
six greed
um the paper tells us the fans should
vote with their feet i mean that's the
problem
that the stadiums are empty and that's
why some of these clubs are finding
they're very short of cash
is it any surprise therefore pippa that
they look elsewhere to generate some
revenue
well i suppose at its heart it comes
down to what clubs are and are they big
corporations that are there to serve
their owners and to you know fill their
coffers or are they community
organizations as they've
been long been seen in this country that
are there to serve their fans and
as as mark has suggested there's been
this sort of tension for a very long
standing for a very long time
it's it's not really anything new but
inevitably
uh coronavirus um has meant that
one of the biggest ways of the clubs
have of sort of raking in the cash
having bums on seats in the stadiums
hasn't been available to them and
of course let's not forget that that has
affected the smaller clubs
and the less you know the ones that
aren't doing by the billionaires so
basically the ones that are not involved
in the super league plan
um the most and some of them have had
some support from the government but
many are struggling financially and
you know this wouldn't make things any
easier potentially if they're sort of
creaming off if you like the sort of the
big clubs and potentially
putting at risk um sort of money that
they can manage to to raise the smaller
clubs from
playing as part of the premier league
and television rights and so on um all
of that's at risk so
you know many are in a dire financial
situation yes but the bigger clubs are
probably more able to withstand it
than some of the others yes i mean the
implications are enormous
um for vast breadths of this sport are
they not
mark the premier league champions league
uefa
whose boss today called them the dirty
dozen absolutely furious
the fa and the guys as we can see in the
daily mail and other papers
of uh of prince william crying foul they
say on this league of greed
him joining in like the government too
against this
yes i think it's probably fair to say if
you were to have a bingo card of things
you don't want to have happen to you
it's the heir to the throne publicly
denouncing what you've chosen
to try to do with your football club and
so that's definitely a bit of a low
from their point of view what you were
just saying about fans
is of course completely is absolutely
crucial to this i'm not particularly
convinced that this is happening
because of the crisis brought on by
covet maybe
the the the option to to think a bit
more
uh outside the box has been spurred by
it to a certain extent
but i think this was probably coming
down the line anyway
a big part of the question isn't why
would these clubs want to
frankly thumb their noses at their fans
in return for money
it's why do they think they can do it
and get away with it and the answer to
that is unfortunately
that that's exactly what they've been
doing for decades and
the question therefore is is your
response to it
buy a season ticket next season buy the
strip
go to the pub when the mat when the
match is on and your pub licensees
paying the fee to
do to air it and if you do all those
things even after this then you're not
disapproving of what they're doing
you're continuing to pay them money if
you really disapprove and disagree of
what they're doing
stop doing those things and they might
have to listen but you understand the
temptation of this this kind of american
model where there's no relegation which
means you get
guaranteed revenue and that means you
can first of all
plan but secondly if you've got
guaranteed revenue
your company or your business is more
valuable so there's the temptation
for this and the idea that asian markets
want to see
the best teams in the world playing each
other all the time that's another big
temptation isn't it
let's move to the guardian uh pippa
number 10 speaking out
both the culture secretary and the prime
minister what can they do about it
that's the kind of the question isn't it
now
well oliver didn't announce um an
immediate fan led review which is going
to be into the
governance of english football which is
going to be headed by tracy crouch
they're sort of very
well respected across the board um
victorian former sports minister
she's a big football fan herself this is
something that the government had
promised in 2019 manifesto but of course
you know the reform of football
governance has been
on the cards for a very long time and
very little has happened up until this
point
but the anger with which this has been
this decision
has been uh proposal has been greeted
has
really feels that they're going to have
to now
um they're going to have to act and
oliver died in the comments today was
making it quite clear that pretty much
everything is on the table
um that for example they could take
legal action the government could take
legal action to stop the formation of
what he described as a cartel-like
league um but foreign clubs could be
banned from coming to the uk to play
games
there could even be a windfall tax on
english clubs that decide they want to
take
part and then one which i think is
particularly interesting is the idea of
fan ownership of clubs now if you look
at
the german system um they have this 50
plus one rule which is that
fans have to own um the members
uh have 250 of a club plus they get one
extra share so they basically have a
sort of deciding vote if you like
and it's notable that that none of the
big german clubs
uh are yet signed up to the super league
proposal and you know makes you think
that that potentially if the
government's holding a fan-led review
does that mean at some point we're going
to have more power back
in um back in the hands of fans and and
community groups
as opposed to the billionaire owners
that definitely want to watch yes i mean
it's hard to completely revoke their
business models i suppose and certainly
alan sugar
former chair of tottenham hotspur was
saying that the the absence of the
german clubs makes this whole prospect
much less attractive in fact um sky
obviously
a big impact um for any company that
broadcast tv rights to this
has put out a statement on the super
league saying in the last 24 hours sky
sports has
passionately articulated the views of
football fans on the importance of
preserving
and sustaining the whole football uh
pyramid and then going on to say we have
not been involved in any discussions
with the proposed breakaway european
super league um because this
rips up all sorts of things doesn't it
if this goes ahead to the
eye now um you'll never go it alone what
is the implication of this that there
there's a chance this won't go ahead
what what do you read into this article
mark
well that's partly about this you know
grand alliance of people who've been
speaking out about it from prince
william
and the fa through to uefa obviously
major
uh representatives of fans other other
people in the industry other
particularly of course clubs who haven't
been invited
um also having their say the big
question of course is that
success in response to what what seems
to be a bad proposal
is not just keep cannot just be keeping
things exactly as they are i think you
need we all need to remember
when the government proposed its
investigation
and review of the reform of structures
of football even if you think
government can get mixed into that with
a satisfactory outcome
which i'm skeptical the reason for that
was it was felt that the existing
structures of the game
are in fundamental ways quite
dysfunctional
so if this proposal ends up accidentally
uh leading to a great big push to keep
things exactly as they are and have been
running for decades
that would that in itself would be quite
a big failure i think the probably the
best way of hope on that is that
tracy crouch as you mentioned isn't just
a a big football fan she's someone with
a great deal of hands-on experience of
grassroots football she's an fa
accredited coach she runs a club
a team in her own constituency and she
is not somebody who suffers
fools or nonsense lightly so i think
she's probably the best hope of getting
some kind of fresh thinking and you know
honest
straight talking on the topic yes well
we've been waiting to hear from
either the big six here or the 12 who
are the basis of this uh this idea
um we're told that florentino perez
president of real madrid
chair of this new super league will be
making a statement to
television later tonight so we'll keep
an eye out for that and maybe have that
by 11 30 when we talk about it
more again then um more though for now
in this program some welcome news on the
covered front the number of deaths
continuing its downward trend are
discussing that after this
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now paper career and
mark wallace welcome back to both of you
um let's talk covid shall we pippa
starting with the news on
india they took their time over this
didn't they yes absolutely i mean boris
johnson has only just
finally now announced that he's not
going to india on his trip
it's planned for this weekend i was
supposed to be one of those going with
him
um and uh miraculously just moments
later
the decision was made that india should
go on the red list of banned countries
for basically
means any arrivals from india um other
than uk and irish citizens uh
aren't allowed and those and british
citizens have to go into into hotel
quarantine now
i think it i think many people feel it
it's a case of the horse has already
bolted
we had uh matt hancock in the comments
today talking about the number of cases
um which have been imported vast
majority of them have been imported to
this new indian variant we don't know
yet whether it's a variant of concern
but obviously it's one that scientists
are keeping their eye on
um and um and then also there's
obviously the concern that this measure
doesn't
come in until 4am on friday which means
there'll be dozens more flights arriving
directly and indirectly from india in
the meantime
obviously india is undergoing a massive
second wave hospitals are overwhelmed i
think it's only 100 critical care beds
left available for population of 20
million people in new delhi it's a
really
miserable situation there so the
decision to cancel the ship seems to be
the right one just probably too late
yes fingers crossed certainly that um
india manages to get it under control as
you say it doesn't look frightening but
the daily telegraph talking about the
situation
here not a fan of lockdown reminding the
prime minister that he wanted
data not dates um with four deaths
reported although i see cases have risen
to nearly 3
000 in in one 24-hour period mark
yes but of course this underscores the
the reason why vaccination has been
so important which is that even if
people who happen to have been
vaccinated do uh become uh
suffer from copyright they get a case of
covert their chance of severe illness
and death is dramatically reduced and
that of course
again underscores just what people are
saying about how important it is that we
protect
that progress we protect the the gains
we have been able to make
from the threats of for example new
variants